the party atmosphere was building early
thousands back on the mall ready for a
concert at the palace
to see the pageantry
being with the atmosphere it's just been
absolutely fantastic i come yearly for
trooping the color just to catch a
glimpse of her majesty
just enjoy the pomp and patrick shane i
come to every royal event
so there's no way i was going to miss
this one absolutely no way
prince william was also getting in the
mood ahead of a concert at cardiff
castle dispatched to wales with kate and
unexpectedly joined by charlotte and big
brother george
it is rare for their children to go out
on engagement but this is a unique
weekend
and a good time for them to start
learning the ropes not expecting the
children to be here as well so that was
an added bonus for
a day to remember forever yeah
there's no doubt the royal family have
wanted to make sure the entire united
kingdom feel part of the celebrations
prince edward and sophie doing the
honours in county down in northern
ireland and what was lovely to see how
relaxed they were interacting with the
crowds and the genuine affection i think
we see not just for the royal family but
for the institution of monarchy embodied
of course by emergency the queen herself
as a family they are getting used to
stepping in for the queen this one event
she will have been sad to miss
princess anne instead receiving a guard
of honor at the epsom derby from her
mother's jockeys past and present
dressed in the royal silks
it was just
an enormous gratitude and pride and
privilege to be able to ride for her
majesty the queen um it's just uh it
seems a lifetime ago now it's over 30
years ago since i last wrote a majesty
awareness 13 years since i retired from
the saddle but even so every time you
see a winner of her majesty's always
fills you with pride as part of the
event they are allowed to film this the
queen relaxed with her horses at the
sandringham stud
after a busy start to the jubilee she
was again at windsor with speculation
about whether she might instead be at a
party for someone else with harry and
megan's daughter lilybet turning one
today and the family sending their best
wishes on social media
as the crowds ahead of the concert and
tomorrow's jubilee pageant couldn't be
making it any clearer how much the
monarch and this moment means to them
[Applause]
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace